責任ある computing とは、
quantum computing をその力を
認識しながら開発することです。
「責任ある」と言うとき、潜在的な影響を踏まえて
技術を開発・活用することが求められます。
それは、事前に定められた原則に基づき、
潜在的な害を防ぎ、軽減するためです。
同時に、積極的に
包括的かつ説明責任のある解決策を推進します。IBM では、
数十年にわたって社会への責任意識が
私たちを動かしてきました。今日、私たちは世界をより良くする触媒と自称しています。
つまり、私たちが構築し活用を支援する
技術の影響を考える責任があります。
私たちが活用を支援する技術の
この新しい技術を開発するにあたり、
今日下す決断が未来に影響を与えます。
そして、これらの決断は
社会に大きな影響を及ぼす可能性があります。
例えば、一部の stakeholder のみを助けるアプリケーションを
追求するか、あるいは
社会問題を解決するものを選ぶか、判断が必要かもしれません。
クライアントである皆さんが、
quantum computing の責任ある開発について考えられるよう願っています。
責任ある思考は、ビジネスが投資家や
消費者との信頼を築く助けになります。
また、誠実さと
従業員からの尊敬を得る評判も築けます。
そして顧客から。一方、
悪評、罰金、
ペナルティから身を守ることにもなります。このビデオでは、
チームで議論すべき重要な責任への考慮事項を
紹介します。
quantum computing を探索する際に
そのアプリケーションについても。quantum computing に関しては、
責任を持って考え行動することは、
一連の原則と
価値観に従うことを意味します。開発を導くための
そして技術の展開においても。
例えば、これは透明性を持つことを意味します。
限界と能力の両方について
quantum computing の。今日の私たちには言語があります。
IBM quantum のクライアントに求める契約条項があり、
私たちのシステムを責任を持って使用することを義務付けています。
また、私たちのシステムを
不正または違法な目的に使用しないことも求めています。
これを「責任ある利用」と呼んでいます。
そして「許容される利用」条項です。
この文言はすでに、クライアントの考え方に影響を与えています。
quantum の開発について
自社のユースケースに向けて考える際に。また、
quantum computing の方向性に影響を与えることもできます。
どのアプリケーションを追求するかを決めることで
開発と加速のために。
技術の無責任な利用から守るために、
私たちは堅牢な IBM quantum safe 技術も開発しました。
quantum computing をどのように、何のために使うかを考える際には、
quantum computing について
期待を現実的に伝えるようにしてください。
quantum computing とそのタイムラインについて
quantum を取り入れることを望む期間についても。
quantum computing を
神秘的なものとして描かず、現実的に説明してください。
computing ハードウェアとして
量子物理学の法則に従うものとして。
quantum computing のユースケースが
積極的に包括的であることを確認してください。
あらゆる潜在的な stakeholder を考慮したものであることも。
その範囲を決定するために
社会的な悪影響の程度を。
ユースケースの探索に向けた
明確な原則と価値観を定めてください。
そして開発においても。ありがとうございました。
ご視聴いただきありがとうございます。
quantum computing を世界にもたらす際に、
それを責任ある形で行う方法も考えていただければ幸いです。
以上です。